I'm doing a lot look ma tell us when we
heard we hear the words Hellfire
paradise you as a former atheist I mean
this is like over the head what tella
get us in the mind of the atheists when
he hears these terms though when I was
an atheist I was I was people of cou far
I was I was hardcore I was a hardcore
kafir I mean I know I know listen up
listen up I was I was a science nerd you
know I I majored in science and then in
college and you know my professors would
make fun of religious people and I would
make fun of religious people you know I
mean I just couldn't understand it at
the time but then you know as you get
older like you start asking deeper
questions you know and I started asking
myself what's going to happen after you
after this is all over after this
there's this after I die what's going to
happen you know I mean first of all I
mean who would come to my funeral and at
that time I knew like very few people
who come to my funeral you know I mean
and then I wouldn't be able to blame
them either because you know if I was if
I died as a non-believer I would go to
the Hellfire right i mean so so then the
funeral would just be a very sad event
right whereas if i died a believer i'll
be going to Paradise and I would want
everybody to have a party at my funeral
you know so I thought it would just be
you know it would it just made sense to
me you know if I died a believer i would
i would like to die a believer anything
to add so professor did you at that time
you were former Christian so did you you
believed in the Trinity that Jesus was
God the Father was God that Jesus died
for your sins was just a common belief
that was prevalent your family there was
both of my parents were actually
christian preachers so in fact you're
finally were Christian preacher yeah
both my mom and my dad and yeah i was
born in in chicago but they were part of
a church that said you needed to move
away from the city so we moved to room
mississippi and we were part of like
this very conservative christian church
in both my my mother
my father they used to who would she TD
jakes no no it's before him I'm not that
young yeah it was basically yeah that
was the the belief of the church in in
our family but as I can say probably
about eight and nine years old I stopped
believing in that but I just didn't know
what other options were out there so I I
never got to the point where I rejected
faith completely like I always believed
in always believed in God I believed in
heaven inhale like my parents are people
of like very very like deep faith like
my mom she she's a type of person that
like we need a new car she would start
buying the stuff for the new car and
like every day she's looking outside
okay you see it yet you see it so that's
the kind of house that I came from so
yeah the Trinity was a part of what we
said we believe but I personally never
didn't believe it and I had a little bit
of like an introduction to Islam my
father joined the Nation of Islam in the
80s so we called ourselves Muslims but
we didn't actually pray or fast we met
on Sunday we mostly like our lessons
came out of the Bible so I just didn't
know like what Islam was until I
actually went to college and got got a
chance to talk to Muslims so you
mentioned your parents were preachers or
your father was a preacher my parents
were preachers my parents got divorced
and my father eventually he joined the
Nation of Islam for a little bit for a
few years he's a part of nature of Islam
and at that time I was a part of what
they call the junior front of his left
just for a very short time and then
eventually like I started going back to
church like in high school but I didn't
really believe in I just didn't know
what else I could do so then you and
your father and your mother accepted
Islam oh just um the the Muslims in my
family are just my uncle who he accepted
islam with with a memoir 13 Muhammad's
community in the 70s he's my father's
brother
myself and my wife was also part
Filipino from California so I wish my
son's we're here to see sheikh mustafa
ala and i have a cousin that also
accepted it and I'm like a few years
after me but none of my siblings or my
parents are Muslim so tell us right now
we know that the Christian faith
revolves totally around Jesus this
relationship with Jesus who we love you
know many people don't know that it's an
article of faith to believe in Jesus you
can actually go to the Hellfire if you
deny Jesus as a Muslim is this right
amen right so tell us what's your
relationship with Jesus now as a Muslim
actually what what convinced me about
Islam I read 22 travels of quran i read
surah Baqarah and that just kind of laid
everything out and the last question
that I had was ok what do muslims
believe about Jesus and so I read absurd
to murder and that just it just
explained what I already believe I just
didn't know how to vocalize it so for me
like accepting jesus peace be upon him
as a prophet that was very natural I
just didn't know like that there was
that option out there so CNN in Islam
just made it like the choice that I
should move so you can you you feel your
relationship with Jesus are stronger now
than it was before that you know him
better his true mission I think in a in
a sense yes but I unlike shake Musa I
haven't exerted myself in studying like
him so I think probably I definitely
could learn a lot more but I think as a
person seeking a type of belief and I
was thinking about this this morning and
it's probably the first time that
actually realized this I think my search
for like the truth was more from a point
of arrogance I wanted to say like this
is the truth and I have it and now I can
tell everybody else about it so like
when I when I touch your heart i used to
debate with the like preachers on campus
and stuff because that's the kind of
family that we came from we my parents
used to preach on the street corners and
stuff like that so
after a few years you see yourself not
progressing with that that methodology
you figure out that maybe there's
something else so I think I'm still even
though I've been muscle for 14 years I
think I'm still trying to figure out
like how to navigate them Pat beautiful
mashallah tell us John have you had some
some interactions with your family and
you know when this whole topic comes up
yeah I've accepted Islam and some people
say has anyone said oh you become a
terrorist has it has ever thought that
curveball be thrown at you how you
respond to that uh a lot of times I just
you know close my eyes and ask I'll
effort to forgive them for their you
know they don't realize what they're
saying they don't realize what they know
I mean a lot of people get their
information about Islam from Fox News
you know and and so that's that's the
whole point of having islam awareness
week here at UIC is so that we can you
know inform the general student body and
everybody else that that Islam isn't a
religion of terrorism or anything like
that you know but it's a beautiful
religion and so it's a it's a it's
something that should bring bring people
together and it should be a you know
like I got like like I tell my
colleagues you know I whenever they
asked me the other social scientist
friends and stuff like that they're like
what's going on with uh with with this
religious thing a guy going on now you
know and and and and I tell them I was
like you know I I understand like the
the the you know this this there's this
air of Islamophobia and stuff like that
going on in the country you know and so
naturally that bleeds over into even
into academia it's you know academics
you know but um I tell them that you
know I i'm bringing you know I tried
sure I try to talk about include
inclusion as opposed to exclusion and I
try to talk about like wait wait you
know we're trying to include everybody
in Islam and trying to like I don't know
I you know my fam my family would talk
about you know this this terrorism stuff
and would what and and and you know I
went I went to I went to a
week-long summer intensive you know to
learn more and and of course my dad
thought I was going to an al-qaeda
training camp or something like that and
I was like no oh it's it's it's a family
oriented thing it's like camp Lawrence
or something like that you know it's
it's a it's nothing crazy no but but
yeah I think I think every converter you
don't have to experience some form of
you know some form of uh you know jihad
like a struggle you know amongst our
families and friends and stuff like that
so she had often mistranslated as holy
war the word jihad means to struggle
Islam does not preach violence it does
not preach vicious holy war it certainly
does not condone terror and suicide
bombing Islam preaches compassion
tolerance and justice find the truth
about Islam call toll-free 877 why Islam
order your free copy of the Koran today
where it can't have defects in it can it
if it is literally God's Word yes it
cannot have defects I mean this was
written by men you know that this is a
collection right even if you have
Matthew Mark Luke and John the Gospel
according to according to write the
thing about the Quran and the biggest
and you know I'll leave you with this is
the biggest thing for me is if the Quran
is exactly what it says it is
and this doesn't matter whether you're
Muslim or not if the cron is what it
says it is the Quran is literally the
Word of God delivered via Gabriel to
Muhammad who was an unlettered man who
couldn't read or write right he was just
told to recite right that was the first
thing right first thing I still resided
right so if it is literally the Word of
God then that's pretty important to me
and before I became Muslim i said if
this is the word of God then I'm going
to follow it because I'd be stupid not
to I am not afraid to stand alone if
allies by my side I am not afraid to
stand alone I am not afraid to stand
alone if a las bombas I i am not afraid
to stand alone i am not afraid to stand
alone
I am not afraid to stay alone
tell us
why is it important now that people
really reflect because when you talk
about religion it's not really the cool
thing to talk about and you might get
some you know heads that turned the
other way but why is it we know the this
Dean this way of life that we practices
is not restricted it's not just a
religion it's a total complete way of
life from A to Z tell us but how do you
get people to really reflect and to take
the matter seriously about the purpose
of life really reflecting why we've been
created what's the purpose of life you
know why is this you know for somebody
out there who's viewing us and maybe
they just you know turned over from up
from a mtv music video and watching the
dean show and we got their ear why is it
really important to contemplate about
the purpose of life when we look at our
existence you know we have the physical
we have the intellectual and there's
also the spiritual and if you neglect
any one of those three you're going to
feel an emptiness and I think sometimes
that's why a person can have everything
in life you know tangibly speaking and
have family you have people who like
them be popular have wealth have status
but they can still feel that emptiness
because that spirituality is lacking so
spirituality is a part of the equation
that you have to tend to and just like
if you ignore your physical you'll get
sick but the only danger about ignoring
your spiritual is that you know you
don't see the ramifications you don't
see the the symptoms because it's
something which is unseen your soul is
not something what you can see the body
you can see so you don't see the
symptoms when your soul gets sick and
when your spirit gets sick and that can
be very dangerous because if you don't
take care of a sickness then it
escalates so spirituality is definitely
something that you have to address it's
not like something you know that I
minority group or people or something
like that some people on the side try to
think it is this is a part of life it's
in the discourse of life something you
should try to address when it comes to
the purpose of your existence and the
existence of God in general it's
something you have to give serious
thought to because chances are you're
probably born into the wrong religion
if you believe right if you believe that
there is one right way or one God and
there's one way that he wants you to
follow chances are you were born into
the wrong religion that's just the way
it is if you look at it from a numbers
perspective so you have to actually find
out why you believe in that's why even
you said right as I think I heard over
heard you speaking that as a Muslim even
as a Muslim there has to come a point in
your life or you choose you want to be a
Muslim just the fact that your mother
and mommy and daddy was Muslim doesn't
make you a Muslim you have to choose
there comes a point where you have to
make a conscious decision and this is an
issue in al-qaeda and theology and and
and the science of theology that is the
Toledo Muslim valid the the inherit can
you inherit faith and the answer by the
most scholars is no right because with
that in what that suggests is that
whoever you inherited from and whoever
you blindly follow if they were to
change you would also follow them in
that so your faith isn't real you have
to make a conscious decision at one
point that yes this is what I believe in
and whoever it was that led me to this
if they left I would stay even if the
person's mother and father left I would
stay so you have to make that conscious
decision and that's why we have to learn
our faith even it's not enough to just
be a Muslim but we should try to also
learn as much as we can and that's I
guess advice for everyone find out why
it is that you follow what you follow
and make a decision for yourself and you
can live with that tell us look man
you've you're going attending the
University correct yeah and have you
taken or for anybody has taken a
philosophy 101 class and now the teacher
the professor comes in and puts on the
board no God here and now the engagement
starts have you had this happen to you
at all have you had or how would you if
you were in this predicament now being a
former atheist now a Muslim how would
you engage with them professor and this
happened
no you you hear this comment happen
where you know it's it's a real scenario
where the teacher comes in and puts no
God and then now the debate opens well
then and I would laugh at them because I
mean then because they don't know what
they're talking about i mean that they I
hasn't happened to me and I don't know I
thought I mean I respect everybody's
beliefs though if you if you don't want
to believe there's a god I mean that
there's there's nothing I can really do
about it I mean I might I mean like if I
was I think the best way to perform Dawa
is actually just to lead by example you
know just just to just delete a clean
life for yourself and when other people
see that then they're more likely to
actually find the truth you know I mean
that's that's all I can really say
beautiful beautiful tell us now
professor we know sharing is caring we
care so we share that's why you know
it's not our job to the guidance is in
the hands of the creator he guides whom
He wills like he guided you guys he
wanted to know the truth he facilitated
away but now you have friends you have
family and you know you start to engage
and your friend or family member says
look man I don't want to follow any
organized religion have you had this
statement come up and how did you tackle
it or if it does come up we hear this a
lot to succumb afraid I don't want to
follow an organized religion it it comes
up i actually have family members and
friends that are very close to me the
one blessing that I think the
african-american community has is that a
lot of us are very uncomfortable with
saying we don't believe in God so at
least to some at to some level like we
retain some some form of faith but a lot
of people are really disenchanted with
what they see in the church and the
abuse that they might have experienced
in the church so they might become
disenchanted from all religions because
they just don't know what else is out
there so the thing that that I try to if
if that conversation ever comes up and
it has a couple of times is that we
usually end up at talking about what do
we think is going to happen when we die
so like if the person believes like
nothing is going to happen
I'm just going to turn to dirt it's very
difficult to to talk beyond that I
haven't figured out a way to to uh to
reason with any with that type of person
where the person believes that like
they're going to be judged based on how
they live this life the things that they
do with their time and their money and
then you can start talking about the
criteria that we should live our life by
usually what I find is that most of my
family they're not they're not against
this non per se and it's actually a good
thing they feel like they can't do it's
not half way so for example if they
drink they're like well I could go to
church and drink like angle to the
matching injury you know or I have a
girlfriend I would have to let her go I
don't want to do that you know so really
I think it's just we continue to pray
that Allah soften their heart and that
eventually they were except this time
and we tried like look man said try to
just be consistent if it's time to pray
we pray if we say we don't eat this we
don't eat it and just be consistent so
they can't find any like inconsistency
in us look what you want to comment on
this yeah I wanted a comment on that so
I mean I was a little bit caught off
guard by your question earlier but uh I
mean so I was talking about performing
Dawa by leading by example and so
actually when I first flew into chicago
the first place I went to was actually
mad at al fatiha which is where Jeremiah
is associated with and so he was
actually calling it done and now you
know leading the prayer and everything
and so actually Jeremiah is actually the
one who invited me to uh to come out to
jummah at UIC and so I mean I knew
Jeremiah for for a little bit more than
a month in everything and at jummah
actually have some students some fellow
students came up to him and said I
missed your lecture can I get the notes
and I was really confused cuz up until
then I thought Jeremiah was just a
little bit older than me you know I
thought thought maybe was a grad student
or something yeah and then I realized oh
you're a tenured professor you know okay
okay well okay okay okay okay my my pet
may be okay but um so then he brought me
into his lab and he had like he's an
electrical engineer who does a lot of
research and does a lot of publications
and I saw like all these grad students
working for him doing all this technical
stuff and I mean it just I just realized
like four
whole month I didn't even know he was a
professor he was just that modest you
know it was that modesty that that came
from this long I think I think if you
could sum up Islam in one word or if I
could sum up Islam in one word I would
say modesty you know so I I think I can
see that you know it I actually have a
question for Jeremiah I mean do I mean I
mean this might be really deep question
but so Eddie asked me what would you do
if if your professor started mocking
religion and so I mean back then it was
actually one of my biology teachers who
was teaching evolution who is was you
know bringing up all this stuff about
the flying spaghetti monster and just
just laughing at religious people but I
mean it seems like Jeremiah doesn't seem
to have that problem Jeremiah is you
know he you teach science right maybe
not biology but I mean dude does that
ever bother you that maybe some of your
some scientific principles like the
scientific method might not really you
know flow with religion at all there no
it doesn't i think like as scientists we
we focus on what we can like study like
what we can like you you you formulate a
hypothesis you design an experiment and
then you like test that hypothesis and
like you draw your conclusions from
there so i think science to me just can
like open another window to like
believing in god but i think is very
difficult i think is a a treacherous
road to go down to try to use science to
try to argue with someone about like
faith because a lot of times and I've
seen this habit you have Muslims that
start arguing about evolution and they
don't know that much about biology you
argue with a graduate student or
scientist in the biologist and they're
going to make you look silly and so that
that makes them think okay well that the
faith is is not right so I mean the i
think was abu hanifa who's radiallahu
and who said uh like if you see a ship
like just sailing in the middle of the
ocean like and someone said this ship
just created him itself and it just got
out there and his guiding itself no one
would believe that so if a person can't
just reflect on that basic level you
didn't structure yourself as you are
like from your fingerprints all the way
down to the color of your skin every
every every feature that we have they
just have to they just have to reflect
and think about it like for me being in
the I guess we say engineering or hard
sciences we don't really have that issue
and also i went to a historically black
college for undergrad which again as I
said african-americans typically are
very religious so we we just didn't have
that issue in undergrad even in
philosophy like I took a philosophy
class I took intro to logic and that
wasn't it the case arguing against God
you know they're they're more so just
trying to sharpen the mind so I haven't
personally dealt with those issues but I
think we just need to be careful when we
try to argue with people and make sure
that this is our strength when we're
debating with people and also debates
only go so far what if someone makes a
mistake or they don't have their
information correct or the person is
only convinced by debates and then after
that high goes down what do they do they
still have to practice so a lot of times
people they fall out of out of Islam and
I've actually seen this I know a guy who
took shower on paltalk and like he was
coming to the master for like a year and
he just couldn't deal with it because he
didn't get that adrenaline rush was just
coming to pray and breaking fast because
it wasn't this like aggressive exchange
so I think we should be a little bit
careful with that I'm not skilled in
debate I don't know how to deal with
that that issue
you worship Jesus no you don't worship
Jesus worship the god of Jesus you
thought you worship the god of Jesus the
one who Jesus fell on his face and pray
to that's when we worship now do we only
believe in Mohammed no we believe in all
the prophets started when the first man
created Adam today round the other son
Jacob and the tribe Moses King Jesus the
last pop was only homelessness I'm
pleased your father so we believe in all
those messages you mentioned who you
mentioned we might and there's many more
so we believe in out all of them yes all
the ones that are mentioned in the Quran
and other than the yeah awesome day you
know you don't worship temple you what
you worship Allah who's the creator of
that but it's part of the belief to
believe in these messages yes your name
like Jesus want to leave them done we
don't worship them don't worship them
yes how important is it now for people
who have come to this way of life we see
it's the fastest-growing way of life in
the world yesterday today and tomorrow
it's constantly people who are really
looking into Islam and they use their
mind they take an academic scientific
approach Islam provides evidence and
proof it's not a blind decision that
people make you know it provides all the
different proves that one would need to
know that indeed it's not an organized
religion by man or men but it's
organized by the one who created man and
men but how important is it now you take
the Shahada okay you declare there's
nothing where they worshipped except the
crater that the creation of Muhammad is
the last and final messenger including
Jesus Moses and all the preceding
messengers BAM you're in but now the
shape was talking about professor was
talking about how you know a person
might have lost that drive so we know
the feel for that is knowledge let's
talk about the importance of continuing
education from the cradle to the grave
because we know it's obligatory at every
Muslim to keep seeking knowledge how
important is this would you say oh
mashallah is keeping a good environment
an environment which will be conducive
to learning about your faith it's it's
definitely necessary
because you have that and we were just
talking downstairs I think that newlywed
phase of a Muslim when you take your
Shahada everything just feels great a
brick can fall on your head and you're
just saying ma sha Allah alhamdulillah
that was from God you know it's okay and
you know you're just happy all the time
and everything is all good you're
praying you're praying you know you're
you're praying in the night actually
when I took my Shahada right my brother
and like my cousin and my friend we
pretty much hung out that night I went
home and our brother we stayed up the
whole night keep in mind they were
Muslim about two months at that time
maybe three months so we stayed up the
whole night and it was a Wednesday night
I'm gonna take my shot we stayed up the
whole night and it was in July so it was
summer short nights early fudger late
mother so it's about 330am and my
brother tells me oh it's about to be
through let's have some breakfast right
now because tomorrow's Thursday when we
fast on Thursdays alright so it was a
sim nuh it was a tradition of the
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him that he would fast on Thursdays
and mondays so you know here i just took
my shot and he's like we're gonna fast
tomorrow right so I was like okay
hamdullah no problem and then you know I
we had our breakfast then fudger came
when we prayed together and I went to
sleep got some rest and I woke up later
that morning and it was really like one
of the best people I've ever experienced
and remember thinking the first thing I
thought when I woke up was I'm Muslim
and I was extremely happy about that and
I was happy too fast I broke my fast I
didn't feel hungry that day right but
that dies out and if a person thinks for
example they have to maintain that or
you need to do that as a Muslim you
might not last so it's it's a marathon
for sure you go in sprinting you're not
going to finish the race but you go too
slow if you go too slow you might not
you know you might fall too far behind
you do have to pace yourself and that's
by putting yourself in good environment
good people people where you can
increase your knowledge with because it
is through knowledge is food for the
soul that's how you feed the soul is
through learning and to stay motivated
it's still learning and you could only
learn through people of knowledge
because you will even burn yourself out
by reading some people getting really
into books and that becomes dry unless
you're really just like that
but that can become dry right you can
lose motivation just from reading but
being around people people of faith
people have practice people of knowledge
this will continue to motivate you all
right so Allah he says in the Quran
right to the people who will enter the
paradise before entering the imperative
of the Holy via a body what the Holy
identity he first will commend them go
with my righteous servants now go into
paradise and that's a lesson for us that
the door to paradise and the road
through paradise is through the company
of the righteous you enter their company
and that will lead you to the paradise
so you have to put yourself in good
environment and good surroundings people
where you can learn from take that
simple step that you ask your maker to
guide you that he'll guide you yes I
advise this a lot so for people in
searching put your head on the floor and
in the in the state of perforation like
all the prophethood and ask the creator
of the universe to show you the way to
guide you to the straight path and
someone who sincerely ask for guided
suppose they'll find it your son that's
it no it's not then everybody watch
can you ready if never eat something can
I am buried some things worry my man
watch the show they did show